[Musique]
joey starr chante claude nougaro le mach
à pessines et didier gustin l'homme aux
cent voire en hommage à un artiste dont
il est fan ça faisait partie des
premiers chanteurs que j'imite aie aie
aie c'est aussi le premier chanteur qui
est venu me voir sur scène en 1987 au
théâtre du tourtour et il m'a dit gustan
tu as trouvé quelque chose maintenant il
te faut creuser et puis un jour j'ai
fait un rêve j'ai rêvé d'un spectacle
qui s'appellerait as tu verras avec des
musiciens avec que la musique quelle
bonne idée
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui vraiment écrivait
vraiment très très bien et même le soir
maintenant quand je joue je découvre
encore ses textes et la qualité de ses
textes et la profondeur parce que vous y
tient mais ça il voulait parler de sa
chimie est bien sûr voilà on m'a dit que
je redécouvre les textes le soir avec as
tu verras didier gustin entraîne dans la
maison jadis habité par claude nougaro
50 invités viennent chercher
l'inspiration d'une mystérieuse
font-elles johnny hallyday eddy mitchell
ou encore raphaël interprète les grands
titres de l'artiste toulousain
e
j'ai voulu choisir les chansons les plus
connues les plus emblématiques
l'emblématique lui aussi celle que
j'aimais et après et après j'ai pris les
interprètes pour qui calais avec dont
quatre boules de cuir quelqu'un qui se
bat qui est costaud j'ai mis johnny
bidonvilles bas lavilliers renault il
faut tourner la page parce qu'il a quand
même tourné une page ce qu'il est revenu
sur scène disparu depuis bientôt 14 ans
claude nougaro laisse un héritage didier
gustin l'avait amené avec lui à montigny
le bretonneux
[Musique]